most people think of time as a river and
that River has been flowing Swift and
Shore for 13 long years since the last
entry in the Prince of Persia franchise
the somewhat aptly titled Forgotten
Sands with Prince of Persia the Lost
Crown Ubisoft appears to be looking to
the past and present in the hopes of
creating a future for the franchise a
return to Prince of Persia's roots in 2D
platforming on the foundations built by
modern metroidvania titles however the
question of whether the game has
anything Innovative of its own to offer
remains to be seen
[Music]
announced at summer game Fest Prince of
Persia the Lost Crown is a 2d action
adventure platformer developed by
Ubisoft Montpellier the studio behind
the Beloved Rayman Legends at a recent
preview event at Ubisoft Montpellier
studio in France we had a chance to go
Hands-On with an early build of the game
playing on both PC and Nintendo switch
for around two hours in a presentation
director munir radhey spoke of a desire
to bring back the core ingredients of
Prince of Persia platforming puzzle
solving time-based powers and a sense of
adventure this new outing is set in a
legendary Persia that is described as an
age of Heroes and gods players take on
the role of Sargon a young and impetuous
hero who is part of a superhero-esque
gang of seven Warriors known as The
Immortals Sargon and the Immortals
journey to mount CAF a land cursed with
time anomalies to rescue the kidnapped
son of the queen of Persia presumably
the titular Prince immediately apparent
is The Game's striking visual style
combining 3D foreground environments
with painterly backgrounds its vast
world is made up of several visually
distinct biomes beams of light beat down
over the deserted streets of the lower
City leaves drift serenely through an
autumnal Forest sand dunes swallow
crumbled ruins in the depths beneath the
city the backgrounds are richly detailed
and are clearly intended to demonstrate
Persia's Rich environmental diversity
beyond the stereotypical deserts and
temples seen in Western pop culture but
always with a high fantasy flavor Sargon
can encounter behemothic beings working
a lava fueled Forge bands of floating
scripture weaving through sand filled
caves and broken statues Frozen in
mid-air Bound by Mount calf's temporal
curse
Sargon explores Mount calf in the way of
every modern metroidvania moving through
environments that make up larger areas
of an interconnected World offering
plenty of scope for exploration
shortcuts and secrets
traversing around the world feels fun
and effortless an obvious result of
Ubisoft montpellier's 2D platforming
Heritage and each area feels like the
product of a team with expertise in
crafting instantly legible flow inducing
platforming playgrounds subtle
navigation awaits occasionally nudge you
in the right direction but many rooms
have multiple exits teasing undiscovered
challenges and rewards our demo did not
include the game's tutorial but that was
hardly an issue as every move you expect
from a modern platformer is present and
correct from an air Dash to a wall jump
and it all feels natural the process of
getting from A to B is a constant
delight and the series Infamous traps
make a welcome return in the form of
platforming puzzles an isolated section
from later in the game showcased a
challenging run which hinted at the kind
of Twitchy Pixel Perfect platforming
Pleasures found in Hollow Knight for
combat encounters Sargon has a pair of
swords at his disposal as well as a
quick fire bow that can transform into a
chakram-esque boomerang dodging and
parrying is fundamental to success there
is no blocking creating a high risk High
reward combat system with enemies
dishing out significant punishment for
poorly timed moves
Sargon also has a variety of combat
powers that seem drawn from the catalog
of generic 2D video game special moves
in our demo these included a powerful
wave attack a lunging thrust and an area
of effect healing spell
certain enemy attacks indicated by
flashing eyes trigger special counter
moves if successfully parried and
function as an instant kill against
grunts or an opportunity to take a
sizable Chunk from a boss's health bar
[Music]
thankfully for a game that rewards
parrying the Lost Crown appears to run
at a locked 60 FPS even on Nintendo
switch and its slick presentation makes
combat feel fluid and responsive and
looks spectacular too sargon's
animations and movements throughout the
world are underpinned by prominent anime
inspired visual flourishes Dash moves
trigger a flash of abstract color and
instant kill parries include Dynamic 3D
camera moves dramatic color shifts and
super satisfying animations it looks
impressive and it's much more than mere
window dressing rather everything is
designed to be in service of how the
game feels much like special moves and
counters in 2D fighting games a
successful Parry is as much an aesthetic
reward as mechanical
Sargon has time Powers at his disposal
thanks to simmer a mythical bird and god
of time and knowledge drawn from real
Persian Legend in our preview these
abilities were limited to an air Dash
and a kind of teleporting power known as
the shadow of simmer players can
crystallize their shadow of Sargon in a
particular place and then teleport back
into it at the Press of a button warping
through hazards and enemies as they do
so though the move is accompanied by a
satisfying rewind sound unlike the sands
of time the power only affects Sargon
and not the world around him meaning
that with some creative thinking on the
part of the player Sargon can navigate
past mobile hazards or pop-up behind
enemies as the shadow can be
crystallized at any point including in
mid-air or during a combo it opens up
many tantalizing opportunities for
combat and exploration simmer is one of
a number of creatures friends and foes
drawn directly from Persian folklore and
for the development team ensuring
accurate sensitive representation of
Persian mythology was key it's clear
that Ubisoft Montpellier sees the game
as an opportunity to show the influence
Persian culture has had on wider
mythology from around the world one boss
battle sees players fight a fierce
semanticore a creature widely seen
across Greek Egyptian and medieval Arts
but the team were Keen to highlight its
roots in Persian mythology there is a
sense that the team is Keen to
acknowledge the franchise's own
mythology too animations frequently
reference past entries such as a
finisher that directly quotes the iconic
acrobatic Vault from the sands of time
trilogy
and a mini boss lifted directly from the
1989 original albeit reworked into a
much more traditional combat encounter
their hope is that the Lost Crown is not
a reboot of the franchise but a love
letter to it with all that said there is
a caveat if this short preview is
anything to go by the Lost Crown feels
an awful lot like a case of familiar
notes being played well Sargon can equip
power bestowing amulets just like Hollow
Knight's charms in an area called The
Sacred archives blind Invincible jailers
hunt Sargon inserted rooms and are
functionally identical to Metroid dreads
Emmys even the in-game conversations
with NPCs strongly evoke the anime style
portraits of Hades much like how
Immortals Phoenix Rising appear to be a
distinctly post breath of the wild
creation it's hard to play The Lost
Crown without constantly being reminded
of the modern greats of the metroidvania
genre and Beyond this isn't necessarily
a bad thing I like Immortals I love
Hollow Knight and I enjoyed why I played
of the Lost Crown 2 but it remains to be
seen whether it offers anything truly
Innovative or simply stands on the
shoulders of greatness we'll find out
when Prince of Persia the Lost Crown is
released in January 2024. for all the
latest Prince of Persia news and for
everything else from summer game Fest
make sure you're subscribed to GameSpot